hey what's up party people welcome to
Honest Trailers commentaries live from a
hybrid version of in studio and out we
are in studio but the lights aren't
working the lights are not working these
are just like the house lights I don't
know yeah I don't know I don't know
these are the these are like if we were
in the room but we weren't filming
anything these are the lights that you
know what I sat in traffic to get here
so damn it we're gonna use the suit
Daniel wisely stayed home hello Danielle
how's it going hey hi doing good
um we're in
um my uh uh all of my gloves uh just in
honor of the Bloodsport yeah um
tournament the Kumite does not use
protection no see they would make me
look really badass except that they're
Galaxy colored for girls
I mean listen
all good if you haven't been here before
Kuma tastes about your bringing your
personal style everybody has their own
everybody has well like no that's a joke
like a third of the fighters have like
their own bit and then the rest of them
are just there to get punched yeah if
you're just in a generic pair of Karate
pants you're getting knocked out you're
just there to get thrown sometimes
picked up by your shirt and thrown out
of the ring which is not I don't think
that's martial arts I don't think that's
enough good flopping we digress we're
starting to talk about about Bloodsport
and and other things that may come up in
the course of that
um this move and we're going to show you
deleted scenes we're going to do uh um
uh questions and comments so so put
those in the chat and then we'll tease
you with next week's which is something
that people like are probably talking
about more currently than Bloodsport
um uh something I never want we're gonna
do talk about it a week from today and
then I hope to never talk about it again
yeah that that's my there's there's your
Michael there's your first clue
um but Bloodsport why are we doing
Bloodsport because we want to
um because this is a great film because
the lawn's ready for the kumate right
here right now
and because there's only like 19 big
movies a year maybe and 52 weeks in the
year and um
slowing down yeah so it's plus more time
baby uh I I really like this I find this
eminently re-watchable there is um even
though uh there's no plot really besides
uh karate tournament
um not really it's just so fun I just
like every even though the side quest
digressions with the cops the bumbling
cops chasing him around and all this
other stuff that could the reporter love
interest traitorist woman thing that
could be cut it's just so fun I like it
all I think that like to day feel it
there's so many like lessons on how to
become a filmmaker in YouTube all of
these launching pads for people to
become professional filmmakers even
student films today have a slickness and
a professionalism but back in the 80s
there was a lot to work and like the guy
who made the the guy who directed this
is an assistant director who worked on
like Godfather part two so I don't mean
to imply that he doesn't know what he's
doing he knows where to point the camera
I'm just saying like there was a
handmade feeling to movies that came out
in this era that we the technology and
whatever has improved to make like
anybody's work can look kind of slick
and professional now but this feels like
a group of people got together and just
like made a movie for fun and there's a
charm to that that is like you can't top
really yeah I would say charm is the
best word to describe it's incredibly
Charming film
um and I saw this as like I don't know
probably middle school or something and
like just there is a coolness to it of
like wow they got all the best martial
artists from all the different countries
and they all have their own kind of
martial arts that's so cool that is why
the UFC exists was to figure out like do
a real life Kumite turns out it's not
cool
um yeah and 75 of them don't work at all
uh but this this movie imagines what if
it did what if it was cool I also feel
like this like inspired I know like Van
Damme's in the movie that they made out
of the video game Street Fighter yeah
but like the video game Street Fighter
and our conception in the 90s of what a
Martial Arts Tournament even was oh yeah
to me is all rooted in this this was my
first vision of what martial arts and
Mortal Kombat was going to be a
bloodsworth uh game exactly so there you
go
um it's all there it's all in the text
so let's read this is like the ER text
of like martial arts fighting for like
white American Kids yeah don't look up
subtext for this there is none yeah
it's amazing that they have subplots but
they don't none that they don't get them
at work or go anywhere they're just
there because you gotta have a subplot
it's a movie they get everything out of
the way in one 11 minute long flashback
like well it's let's let's watch
the way it is
from Canon the studio behind the brick
and franchise the courty Cox He-Man
movie and the ninja cinematic extended
Universe comes a film based on the
completely made of fantasy of a con
artist named Frank dukes and it's
[__] awesome this is exactly how I
lie about myself too
on those stats love it love it I love
this I mean how how would you know this
who would keep these records yeah 72
miles per hour like what are they they
got the little the little speed trap gun
by the side of the the ring and they're
measuring the funny thing is like he
knew that obviously somebody could
probably kick that fast or faster in the
world so he had to add the caveat with a
knockout with a knockout
sanctioned bat because surely somebody
can kick that fast but no with a
knockout it's so great before the
internet you could really just lie yes
this is a great free internet uh liar um
Frank dukes and then I love consecutive
Knockouts in a single tournament if
there's 56 rounds in a tournament that
must include everybody on Earth yeah
if you have a 52 person bracket he made
it to the elite 800. it was really
impressive I think yeah if somebody does
the math on that I think that's like
more atoms in the universe if there's a
56 rent like because the final four like
the the March Madness starts at like 94
and that's final 4K and they have to win
like eight games in a row so if you have
to win 56 martial arts knockout
tournaments it's amazing none of it
really holds it doesn't really make a
lot of sense none of the none of the
math works out and yet he got away with
it for for like decades it'll be LA
Times finally like busted it was like I
read none of this really in sixth grade
I read Frank dukes's autobiography I
didn't know at the time that he was a
liar oh the secret man is a CL it was
called the secret Man by Frank Dukes um
and this is something that I need to
find again and and dig up um because
this is a talk about an ER text for me
it was like okay this is what I want to
do I want to become a ninja yeah I want
to join become ninja join the CIA and um
I uh the the thing that really uh uh put
some stuff in my brain is that he he
tells a story about how he um seduced a
woman on on a mission by uh setting off
the sprinklers the fire sprinklers that
like that made her shirt so wet that he
could rip it off more easily sure yeah
don't try that if anybody watching just
like that that's just a Frank Dukes move
you can't do that only Frank dude that's
exclusively that's like the sexual
Democratic technology yeah that's Brave
harder to rip off if it was like logged
with water I'm not gonna do the physics
of it Frank didn't why should I yeah
Frank's not bothering to do the action I
just love that yeah like for like 50 20
years people were like sure Frank and
then finally a guy in the L.A times was
like should I look should we look up any
of this call the Marines and see if they
know a guy named Frank Dukes they do not
no they do he just never left San Diego
he was in San Diego yeah that's the
cover story though
one his like one um reported injury is
that he like fell off a boat that he was
painting literally fell off a turnip
truck
hit a bump
and now uh but that was Again cover sure
because that's that's what they want you
to think um that would it would like
could someone should do a Confessions of
a dangerous mind type like what if Frank
Dukes has been telling the truth the
whole time like we've all denied him
greatest trick Frank Dukes ever go but
secretly this whole time has been like
the greatest ninja in the world and we
just don't appreciate his efforts yes oh
man I gotta someone
um well I found the link I'm gonna
reread the secret man and next week
we'll do a book report instead of
instead of next week's commentary I
think we mentioned it in the trailer it
is hard like he not only because in the
movie they just call his master Tanaka
but in the book apparently he calls him
tiger Tanaka which is the name of the
guy and you'll Only Live Twice who
trains James Bond Duke no also based on
a true story my my favorite Frank Duke's
uh invention there stole the bot guy's
name
what sport
back in the 80s Arnold and Sly had the
guns Seagal had the chops
but only Jean-Claude Van Damme had the
cakes suit up or what may not be his
first credited role but it's the first
time he'll play a martial arts master
from America you're not even trying to
understand what this means to us are you
with the loosest hamstrings in the West
hurts me just looking at it great for
rocking the splits bad for keeping the
beat
[Music]
journey to Hong Kong home of the top
secret I'm talking about just jcvd in
general and I think he's held up
remarkably well save for maybe like
Schwarzenegger and Stallone but like
compared to Segal sure
um well I don't want to throw Dolph is
amazing like but both both jcbd and
golfer in those uh that universal
Soldier direct to video sequels which
are amazing by the way the last two
universal Soldier okay uh DTV sequels
that they did they brought back Van
Damme and Dolph Lundgren Scott Adkins
this guy was going to be in uh John Wick
4 he's in them yeah amazingly Good Day
of Reckoning is crazy the last one they
did nice it's John Hines Peter heim's
kid okay anyway but I certainly put him
above
um like a Chuck Norris yeah well because
he always had kind of he's got a little
bit more of a sense of humor about
himself and a little bit more I think
like self-awareness about his place in
the filmmaking world yeah like a Segal
or a Chuck Norris you know like I feel
like he can do stuff like a jcv VD that
sort of sends up his image or even
Expendables where he's Jean valaine
like I think he could be fun in a role
like that and you can count on him to do
like you know he's got a little bit of
comic chop yes definitely and the splits
are great and uh I mean what a physical
specimen in uh in late 80s
insane I mean uh and like less uh less
overtly roided out than the other ones
um I'm sure it was the 80s there were
some stuff going on but it looks it like
that looks like a guy who trains all day
he looked like a guy that trains all day
and could do martial arts
um you believe he's like doing the
splits on top of a skyscraper in
downtown Hong Kong when there's
re-watching Under Siege even even Peak
Seagal looks ridiculous
yeah they they are they often do the the
chest up yeah for Seagal where he could
do a lot of this but you don't see the
body moving so it's just like just his
hands moving fast there's a lot of that
props to Jean-Claude
um and they set the template for all of
his characters the quest is amazing I
recommend everyone go see the quest uh
kickboxer a great great dance scene of
course and I mean this is but this to me
is is this is the like the I mean
Lionheart
uh fun stuff and but double team yeah
double team is amazing
I was thinking of Double Impact where he
plays the Dual role both Sensational
Jack them both down yeah uh saw them
both in theaters yes it did what's the
one oh what's the one with
um with Natasha Henstridge maximum risk
that he did with Ringo lamb that one's
pretty fun too oh all right my jcbd
watch list and one more Sudden Impact
Powers Booth is the vice president who
gets taken hostage at the hockey arena I
believe Pittsburgh Penguins yeah that's
a that's that movie that's Jason they
remade that it's die hard in a hospital
yeah which is different yeah they remade
that with uh Michael J white and um okay
great great yes yes they do or it's a
sequel I think it's not even a remake
it's like Sudden Impact 2 or something
um anyway anyway the fact that there's
no reboot or sequel to Bloodsport is
like good but also like why didn't they
or why haven't is it is it the Frank
Dukes thing like if you were remaking
this you'd have to pay Frank Dukes again
for his life story and the fact that
he's just like a blatant fraud is I
think he's still alive they should just
do it like um what's that very meta show
well that's not something they should do
like Confessions of a dangerous moment
yeah yeah you know all right we we've
cracked it uh okay keep going were you
thinking of I didn't mean to arrive
what's the what's the one with the that
guy who's a liar it's like halty Goldman
yes perfect yeah that's exactly that
that is exactly how you should do it
that's not what the show what's the show
called Paulie Goldman it's called Paul T
Goldman it's on peacock it's an
incredible really good job oh yeah keep
going I'm fighting tournament known as
the kumate tomorrow we leave for the
kumate I heard you get killed with that
coma team like I said a top secret
detour here for the kumate aren't you
we'll talk about
and you can see me fighting the Kumite
I'm here too for the top secret
underground
we all know that the Kumite is happening
here Express leaves in five minutes a
top secret underground someday I'll find
out
proud okay forget it a well-known
fighting tournament with its own event
staff flag team and co-sponsors
international fighting Arts Association
has co-sponsor there he'll have to
navigate a single sketchy Alleyway eBay
police were easy to fool then and enter
your birthday papa
good
shower I waited and disappeared
[Music]
the fiction that Frank Dukes is asking
you to believe is that he's so valuable
to the United States military that they
will like spare no expense if he goes if
he's missing they will send a team to
like where they will uh you know co-opt
the Hong Kong government and they will
do hell move hell or high water to bring
this man back to San Diego because he's
that valuable yes as far as Whitaker and
then so like a character actor I don't
recognize but they give that that the
old guy this incredible beat where he
just has to do that like if something
were to happen to Frank do
I don't know if America would make it I
don't know what he says but it's like
it's literally like the
feet of the United States hangs in the
balance right if Bank Dukes dies in a
Martial Arts Tournament the whole
country is screwed he's carrying the
world on his hamstrings the global
balance of power relies on America
having friends
yeah it's just so beyond like it like
professional athletes like they're it's
in their contract they're like you can't
go snowboarding right because you might
hurt yourself right but but they don't
like send uh the colors Whitaker with
like a really old school taser like
they've got these tasers but they don't
look like taser they're these huge they
look like the drumsticks you get in
medieval times they're like turkey legs
like this big it's like the equivalent
of like today's cell phones versus an 80
cell phone it's like today's tasers
versus an 80s taser they're just huge
that's the kind of taste you need to
bring down Frank face he could he could
just brush off a smaller taste it's like
a dinosaur it's like
like Jurassic world films the tasers are
small yeah they're amazing um done more
taser talk oh well uh okay keep playing
racism to fill a two-hour Tucker Carlson
rant why don't you quit did teach me you
are not Japanese you Jackson
you look like a Jackson he's the
American who makes chicks with Brits you
don't look like Tanaka the Kumite
Administration wants you to be ashamed
of your heritage they make Paco prove he
can chop a coconut and a half to enter
no yeah Frank Dukes has to perform the
Denmark Touch of death technique simply
for being belgian-american meet Frank
Dukes the inspiration the true events of
this film sure the real Frank's military
record shows he never left San Diego he
claims he sold his Kumite trophy sword
to Pirates
that's one of my favorite Frank Dukes
lies is um they're like well Frank okay
if you went to the Kumite and they
awarded you this sword we all see the
grand prize is a katana yeah where's the
sword
um here's the thing about the sword so
he went to rescue a gang of a group of
children who had been kidnapped by
Pirates as one does as one does and he
the the Pirates had somehow you know uh
cornered him or turn the tables where he
was able to sell
if you will
to rescue the children um he he
successfully brokered the child for
sword for child deal yeah sure
um and he has he says that he maintains
to this day uh the children maintain an
ironclad loyalty to Franklin right with
his army he has an army of children of
rescued pirate children that would kill
on his back so he could send them out on
missions for him on his behalf yes so um
that's great and there's no girls
allowed
um and if tank starts feeling tired you
have to remember the clap
all right keep going Captain Phillips
also based on Frank Duke
heard of his Sensei can be found but he
happens to have the same name as a James
Bond character the ninjas worthy James
Bonds of Japan oh okay but that's just
his CIA cover story as we learn about
his life in an 11 minute long flashback
slash training montage that Frank wasn't
always a Hitman ninja who secretly won
the Medal of Honor and was once an
extremely slow boy
the San Francisco Giants and New York
Giants were different teams go sports
however under the highly erotic tutelage
of the tanakas
[Music]
he'll transform into a shredded kicking
machine to honor his master or Avenge
the duty just met whatever Frank is just
here to kick some ribs and bust some
nuts
how is that a legal move
to Unforgettable Side characters like
Janice the love interest and traitor
because when you only have one woman in
your movie they have to play both
this you're saying is a recurring
character in a lot of Jean-Claude Van
Damme's uh well in just action movies
and Daryl's the reporter female reporter
like a lot of a lot of female reporter
but then there's also like she really
does she fulfills like three different
roles in this movie because at first
she's like I want to know more about
this Kuma tell me get me into the Kumite
and then as soon as she finds out about
it she's like you should never do the
kumate again this is dangerous and
you're gonna well because she falls in
love right
you can't ruin our our love with the
Kumite and then at the end she's the
trader who goes to the government and
reveals the kubita yeah uh again one
woman
they have to do the work of three men
three male roles
she has these dramatic changes of heart
about the Kumite what did she say think
it was before she went
well yeah she knows what it is in theory
but it's a secret No Holds Barred
fighting tournament I am so upset when
she realized like she thought they were
kidding about the people oh yeah the
reaction shots of her the Kumite are
horrified like oh oh it's the it this is
what you came to see you came to see
akumita what did you think akumate was
yeah
Danielle were you saying something
oh no no no no
um no
all right I was I was just singing the
kumato song to myself over and over
again it happened all week yeah other
love interest if you ever need me I'll
be there I love you my friend and
waiting at the end of it all is
legendary villain Chong Lee a fighter
who already has his try again pose ready
for his Street Fighter character who's
so evil he tastes his own blood ah yes
still evil good Hans Frank's nightmares
like a raptor on an airplane
ah
and purposely hurts people in this No
Holds Barred hurting people tournament
[Music]
foreign
they're going crazy they love it oh
Chong Lee's back can't get enough of
murder we're here to see the murder
fight
um he did he gave us exactly what we
wanted what changed the whole picture
would say is like me you might die in
full contact we don't stop the fight
before people die I kind of always felt
like the one bit of subtext that is in
this movie
um is that like
Frank was so inspiring in the way that
he was able to do everything that um
that Chung Lee could do but without
resorting to killing that it made people
believe they could be better there's a
better way yeah yeah so he really he
didn't just win the Kumite he saved it
he saved it he did
some straight Kumite questions
um
one uh the arena change that they do at
the end to like make it sort of a half
pipe yeah why what that wasn't used at
all there was it wasn't explained does
that make fighting any better why did
they do that yeah I don't know um two
tradition I feel like they've just kind
of the the Kumite in real life they've
just backed their way into creating sumo
wrestling because if you can win by just
pushing somebody off a very small stage
it's so much easier to just shove
someone off a small platform or in the
case of Ray jackson
toss them Popeye style is it just like
an honor thing or have they just not
figured it out yet that it's easier to
just shove someone off a small raised
platform than it is to beat them
unconscious
I feel like it's got to be the honor the
honest thing like you wanna you wanna
win quickly and you want to win by like
a devastating knockout blow I just feel
like there's like a money ball of Kumite
where they could get a guy who's really
good at shoving and just enter them in
their dog it's boring but he keeps
winning he just steamrolled through it I
like the idea of yeah Brad Pitt and
Jonah Hill in the back of the Kubota
Arena you know like you know a guy could
just shove really hard
um that's uh what was that movie Push
that's the move push should have been
about a really good shovel just a really
good shoving yeah just shoveling all
right those are my kumate thoughts all
right keep going
enjoy 90 action-packed minutes
what's the referee doing there yeah why
the ref they just use them as a platform
to jump off and like he's just there to
check the pulse and go
oh like this guy's dead remind you to
make a bigger face like right before you
go for the kill he's like yeah okay okay
that was the final Kumite thought keep
going
fighting styles to find the characters
let's the crazy faces do the right faces
and let's the sweet sweet music sit the
mood such a good soundtrack
[Music]
because the last thing you want out of
this film or when they let the words
tell the story well I'm just trying to
be the best I can be not just for me
too go right ahead
the heads and are worth so slip into a
comfortable pair of Karate pants and
re-watch the most influential film ever
made that's responsible for those early
years of UFC before he realized martial
arts don't work Inspire the entire
Mortal Kombat franchise when the rights
to jean-claude's likeness fell through
and fueled an American president's rise
to power Mr Trump I may not share your
politics but I salute your commitment to
making people watch Bloodsport and fast
forwarding through the talking Parts
everybody read that oral history of
Donald Trump's obsession with Bloodsport
uh yeah he he makes people watch the
movie on VHS and fast forwards through
the parts which are great too yes I I
will say potentially overblown we have a
few individual anecdotes of trump
putting on blood Sports sometimes
turning off other movies that did not
interest him into favor of Bloodsport
yeah and then skipping ahead to the
fighting part but we don't we don't
really have I don't think we can say for
sure that it's his favorite movie that's
a common claim on the internet come on
we have evidence that President Trump
former president Trump big fan of blood
yeah we could save that with confidence
what would he like better I I open that
to you commenters whether it be like
also that great Errol Morris clip of him
talking about citizen case clearly not
his favorite movie movie but highly
recommend it also yeah uh I can't
imagine a better fit for what his
favorite movie would be so so let us
know it feels right yeah yeah all right
it's like a road map yeah
hey kumate USA Kumite
story damn Yankee heat fighter
undercover bother Ghost Dog Origins
Sword Art offline apex predator and
Wonka and these guys with one or two
small moments but boy do they make them
count mob guy finding a gold tooth
threatening hand gestures guy
USA
[Laughter]
so good
Frank Dukes has to think about his whole
life before he fights a dude I love this
it opens with like a flashback and then
like a Time skip within a flashback and
a training montage they're like let's
just get everything out of the way
before the fighting tournament starts
like real real quick 15 minutes in
you've got all the play settings you
could possibly do yeah everything you
need
um thank you all for watching thanks for
sticking with us through Bloodsport uh I
know it's not the most SEO friendly
movie uh but sometimes you gotta do the
ones that we want so we can get to the
ones that I guess you want it's not in
this how does this connect to Kang is
this phase five or six Chun-Li is
Mephisto I will also uh um complain
about uh YouTube and SEO and analytics
from from last week when uh we posted
the Titanic one and it was off to an
amazing like you know super good start
uh and then we got flagged for
inappropriate contact uh content because
we put the um the Rose reclining nude in
the thumbnail
but we didn't show anything no we didn't
show anything no no goods were shown but
we got flagged for inappropriate content
because of that last week which is very
annoying YouTube I really
this full horrible things that go up on
YouTube yeah all fine but it tasteful
from from this part up it's no good
ridiculous
um so I guess let's collarbone Kate
Winslet's covered up uh uh decolletage
flag flag the YouTube the YouTube scolds
the YouTube woke scolds they won't put
that up there so oh well uh a lesson
learned hour-long misogynist rants great
oh yeah I recommend them yeah Adam
um but so yeah we'll uh uh uh we'll
we'll address that going forward no more
no more fun in the thumbnail everybody
everybody's gonna be dressed like a
goody Proctor
rocks for Bed Head To Toe do you have
any uptakes for this one I think we
might have a few alternate starrings
story
the Dukes of Hazard more rehearsal
Soldier
nerds Action Jackson Jack blackout super
trash Brothers Lois Lane raw Guerrera
Chong Lee wins train man Senpai notice
me you are not Japanese neither are you
Roy Chow Hot Shots Park Dukes
stretch me if you can
bullshito
American Ninja Warrior
Fight Club
that's the best
I'm just I gotta keep it PG-13 now
she's got a flag but I think that they
actually stop the AI or whatever stops
watching after like 18 seconds or
something they don't swear in the first
like 15-20 seconds that's something good
so good all right now we'll just we'll
make next week's trailer oh [__] I'm
gonna cool me down
that's really good sometimes you think
of a good one
[Music]
your comments Trevor copter how does it
feel to be GD Legends for finally doing
Bloodsport it feels so good man it feels
so good so good yeah uh honestly like
there are I really feel like there are
fewer big movies these days
um and that leaves a lot of openings
because we've already done every big
Legacy movie at this point 10 years on
so we now get to do our favorite movies
that's the new policy right so it's
tough because we the most obvious
corollaries for everything that comes
out we most of them we've done we've
never done Karate Kid but we'll we'll
get there eventually
um well when the the final season of uh
of Cobra cup yeah that would be a
perfect moment yeah
um so yeah expect more Bloodsport more
more Commando uh just the gems that like
yeah I got somebody was saying like okay
you've got finally we did Bloodsport
next 80s classic we got to do is
Commando and I I'm inclined to agree uh
Jim one says we'd love to see a
groundhog day trailer for its 30th
Anniversary this month or is it too
perfect to release that I think that is
a perfect film I have nothing to say
except for that I'm about Groundhog Day
it's tough I mean I guess you could dig
into like the alternate versions like
how we know you know there was like the
much Bleaker sort of ending or something
you could talk about like that but yeah
it's tough to like criticize Groundhog
Day it's basically yeah
uh Adam Halbert a little off topic but
we'll get back to Bloodsport uh with
these over Complicated new subscription
rules that are alienating subscribers
how much longer can Netflix last I think
it can last
forever but it'll probably cost more and
they'll make less they'll make fewer
shows right like I think that there was
that Wall Street uh correction when they
when they finally missed their
subscriber targets or they shrank
instead of Gru where it's like oh okay
the free money the free money hose is
over uh now you have to show that you
can make a business
um because they're not profitable or
they are they if they are it's very
recent yeah I I think they can be if
they spend less on yeah and that's the
only way is spending less and charging
more and they're they're all I mean
we're seeing this across the board every
every subscription VOD service they're
all switching focused they they added
subscribers they've now kind of maxed
out the subscribers they can easily get
in most big markets and so now they're
going to shift focus on profitability so
yeah that's going to mean yeah
somebody's gonna die like like peacock
or or they'll just keep consolidating
consolidate yeah exactly some will be
absorbed well next is almost definitely
Stars Lionsgate is looking to split the
Lionsgate Film Studio from the Stars
cable network and streaming service and
so once they separate Stars becomes a
prime acquisition Target like somebody
would grab that right away and then I
feel like you know Stars plus Paramount
plus Stars Plus Peacock Stars plus
Amazon like and there's also this weird
sort of analog back to
um syndication where it's like oh like
isn't HBO like selling Westworld to 2B
or something like that yeah it already
did so they pulled a bunch of stuff from
HBO Max and then they're going to put it
on too because they can sell ads on it
yeah so the idea is a lot of these
catalog shows if they're not getting
watched that much they're gonna be worth
like Raised by Wolves is another one of
those HBO shows so like how many people
are really signing up for HBO Max at
this point to watch Raised by Wolves
almost nobody right for free on 2B maybe
but if it's streaming on 2B you could
sell ads against it and you can make
money off of that show that otherwise
would just be sitting on HBO numbers
that Joss Whedon won that's also on 2B
now as well which was how syndication
worked where it's like oh Seinfeld is on
TBS now like they're just it's just
making money every year passive income
for all of these it's past vid because
it's free real estate yeah exactly
free real estate it's free real estate
uh Joseph Kaufman back to Bloodsport was
there a martial arts style fake or real
that you wish would have been
represented at the tournament
I feel like an actual ninja would have
been cool like some real Ninjutsu like
oh where is he where is he then he's
like yeah smoke bomb oh he's in the
rafters yeah anything else capoeira I
just want to see break dancing yeah and
I think there was sort of a capoeira guy
there's a guy who's doing like Monkey
Style like yeah he's jumping around like
and that's not a real martial art but I
think I read that his his monkey style
is very heavily inspired by Captain okay
so he's doing kind of capoeira moves but
making it look like it's a fighting
style a regular boxer would have been
cool like ball rug and yeah and Street
Fighter
um there's so yeah that's that's the
thing is like that's what's so cool
about this and why what why it makes a
perfect video game is everybody's
bringing their own thing
um which in real life sucks but in
movies super cool it's cool yeah yeah
you get to see a variety you know like
it's fun it's fun from that perspective
uh let's see uh Lo says Bloodsport or
the exact same movie Jean-Claude Van
Damme made eight years later the quest
yeah I think the quest is better but I'd
rather watch Bloodsport I gotta re-watch
the quest I I do remember loving it so I
think I actually liked it more on first
viewing but I've seen Bloodsport so many
times that it's like oh here comes this
part uh so I gotta re-watch the Quest
for sure love both but I think it's the
same thing I always talk about where
it's like the quest feels more like a
studio movie like a real movie a movie
like a movie
theater and see a movie but uh
Bloodsport has that handmade a bunch of
friends got together and made a movie
charm that I don't think the quest court
has uh we'll close with this from f j
pretzer if you could put Al in the
Raptor in any actual movie to make it
better what would it be I say 50 Shades
now we I imagine this is like a dream
where a raptor says the protagonist's
name or the is that what makes it the
Allen raptor is it just like adding a
Raptor
Alan the Raptor is a dream creation yes
he's having a nightmare about going back
yeah so what movie would you add a
nightmare about uh where a raptor says
your name oh
God uh well I guess that's our show is
that our motion sensors or did we just
leave the lights entirely oh emotions
get up and move around a little bit I'm
trying
no like around the corner I think it's
the sensor's over by the door
my screen's Frozen so I can only hear
what's happening
oh so hey
I have a dream of a rep of a nightmare
Raptor and uh I I a recent film I I
watched recently that they could
definitely have used a nightmare Raptor
skinamarink Skinnamarink yes he's one of
the one of the rooms in the skinamarink
House suddenly there's an allen rafter
yelling the kid's Nick Kevin I think
it's the kid's name it's skinamaroo
that's good
um that's good
I think like uh like a taught uh
Thriller like uh like Michael Clayton
it's just to break up the tension like
Mike Swinton Falls yeah
Michael he wakes up yeah I'm gonna go
with Michael Clayton Danielle what are
you putting Raptor in
uh Gone With the Wind okay
look at Rhett or Rose
oh I think
Scarlet yeah red or Scarlet so the
Raptor says Scarlet yeah Scarlet Scarlet
yeah
it has a little mustache okay yeah
House of Gucci if she had a dream yeah
Raptor saying her name would have been
really good I could see that actually
fitting into that movie there you go all
right that's all for Bloodsport before
they fully cut the power on us and make
us go home yeah um kicking and screaming
but uh we just don't want to talk or
think about next week's honest trailer
um that's your clue because it's been
done okay so you know how in TV shows
when you're making a TV show and then a
character shows up you know what always
happens this this
all right see you next week I wanna die
I want to die
[Music]
thank you